as the watches that I'm really
interested in seeing play out is the
Green Line trend so everybody got very
attached to local food easily will got
attached to organic food very easily now
in viticulture there of course are the
parallel challenges and you want your
grape vines tended you know without too
much intervention and there are a lot of
wine makers who have been making organic
wine or wine from organic grapes and for
a long time and they're finally going to
start marketing that is that going to
work I don't know I'm interested in
seeing how that plays out because I
think there's a huge opportunity that's
real and then there's the opportunity
that's marketing and unless those two
things come together must be terrible
wide um the other trends that I'm really
interested in I'm interested in the
better whites so you know poor
Chardonnay such bad reputation it's been
over oaked in America for so long and
now we've pulled back you know so you
can actually get a really great
Chardonnay that's made in America and of
course in France always been possible
but um but the other White's that have
come on the scene they have so much
flavor and i think that there's a light
and refreshing and people sort of
rejected them because they know if
there's going to be drinking the wine
they should drink red but i just want to
be a white wine booster so i'm all over
the white wines a great gewurztraminer
great viognier a great albariño um a
great Moscato so I'm really interested
in that um I'm interested in the and not
just me I said oh you know there's a
swelling of interest in the boutique of
champagnes so champagne has been
dominated by their really big brands
which are fantastic but now they're
these like little these small houses
doing incredible boutique champions and
they're now coming to the states it used
to be that they just didn't make enough
that it wasn't worth the export but now
you can see
phenomenal champagne lists and
restaurants and in wine stores
interesting that um I'm interested in
you know Reds that are not California
cabs so i'm interested in the the local
global varietals if that makes any sense
so I'm interested in Malbec you know i'm
interested in the greek grapes that I
whose names I absolutely cannot
pronounce I'm interested in having them
I mean I could but I'm not going to try
and I'm interested in in those
introductions of all the greek wines
because Greek wine and food is such a
huge trend um and I'm glad for because
it's very healthy very fresh cooking and
great and the ones you know have come
along with it so um there's so the wine
world because of the global interest in
higher quality you know in geek terms
they've reduced yields which means that
they're not producing wines that are is
maybe grab your thin but they're better
concentrated their better taken care of
in the vineyard people say you know wine
is really made in the vineyard which
means they care more about the grapes
and so there's a lot of great great wine
around the world we don't allow that the
wine in Tuscany right chianti where um
they're great Sanjeev is is great but
the the truth is um there's wines in the
south of Italy like campania Sardinia's
Sicily and those ones had not really
come into the States before and so I
encourage everyone to go look for you
know sardinian sardinian wines and and
have some Fraggle of while you were at
it which always sounds very Jewish to me
fregola but it's not it's a Sardinian
pasta and and the ones of Campania and
and you know not just get stuck on
why would ask me